so the last time we we tried to to film
chlorine experiments we found that the
chlorine cylinder itself had a slight
problem it was seized here but the Stig
has acquired another cylinder of
chlorine so you know what this means it
means that we feel duty-bound to
increase the intensity of our chlorine
video and show you some chemistry with
chlorine
chlorine is an element that many people
have heard of it's a greenish yellow gas
and which consists of the gas consists
of two chlorine atoms bonded together so
it's cl2 and it's much heavier than air
incredibly reactive incredibly poisonous
not a very nice compound at all
okay so Neil is about to to open the
cylinder of chlorine to allow some
chlorine gas to leak through the pipe
into the to the flask in the fume hood
chlorine sits in the right-hand side of
the periodic table and the halogens in
group well some people say seven some
people say 17 really what that says is
that chlorine wants another electron to
get that noble gas configuration and it
will move heaven and earth to get that
electron so during the First World War
it was used as a chemical weapon the gas
could spread across the battlefields and
when it came to the trenches which were
holes in the ground it would fall into
the trenches and fill them up you can
see the yellow color against the white
background on the paper so now we're
starting to fill that flask with
chlorine it's quite dense so it will
stick to the bottom of the flask it's
not like a light gas like hydrogen or
helium it won't come upwards so now you
can see the color in that chlorine is
really quite intense it wasn't a
terribly good weapon because it could
quite easily if the wind changed
direction it could blow the gas back to
the people who were letting it out so
we'll just put a stopper in to contain
the gas while we prepare the rest of the
experiment chlorine is quite corrosive
it reacts with water to make an acid HCl
hydrochloric acid which can attack
people's lungs the lungs generate fluid
that they fill up with fluid and quickly
the person drowns in their own fluid it
also corrodes things very easily so all
the metal fittings on people's battle
dress that
brass buttons brass buckles all went
green as well but it's not a terribly
effective weapon but when people weren't
expecting any sort of chemical weapon it
must have been terrifying okay so we
have a small amount of aluminium here
which we put on the end of a wire we're
going to heat the aluminium in that
flame and then we're going to put the
hot aluminium into the flask of chlorine
and hopefully we'll see the chlorine
will react with the aluminium and we'll
get very rapid formation of aluminium
trichloride a alcl3 the british army
created whole regiments of gas soldiers
who were all trained chemists who were
sent out to handle these cylinders of
gas and on the german side in the First
World War
Fritz Harbor the inventor of the harbour
process to make ammonia became very keen
on chemical weapons and he was the chief
proponent his wife was really furious
about this and in fact shot herself with
his revolver killed herself the day
before he was due to go back to the
front and he it was said that this was
because she objected to his work on
chemical weapons though at the same time
there were rumors that he was having an
affair with another woman so there may
have been other factors at play as well
so let's heat up our aluminium
okay so it's nice and warm all over
and then we'll drop it we'll add it into
the chlorine gas
now instantly we're seeing aluminium
trichloride coming out at the top and
reacting with moisture in the air so now
you can see that the reactions getting
very intense and we're seeing a flame in
the bottom so the aluminium is being
consumed as it's reacting oxidizing
strongly in that chlorine rich air
chlorine is found all over the world the
sea contains sodium chloride and there
are huge deposits of sodium chloride in
salt lakes where lakes have dried out
such as in some parts of the states
where you have United States where you
have salt lakes where people can race
cars and things across the flat surface
and in other parts of the world
all of the aluminium has been consumed
now by the chlorine very very rapid
reaction there are many areas such as in
the north of England in the county of
Cheshire and also in Salzburg in Austria
where there are prehistoric deposits of
salt from prehistoric salt lakes which
can now be mined really quite easily and
there so salt and chlorine is a very
common element
it's made from sodium chloride solution
by electrolysis bypassing electric
current and it's a very energy intensive
process 1% of the UK's electricity was
used at one time for making chlorine
from sodium chloride and the chlorine is
used particularly for making the plastic
PVC while we got chlorine here
I thought we do a couple of reactions so
we've got some chlorine in this flask
and you can see the nice yellow colour
and I thought what we try and do now is
do a competition reaction again or a
reaction with iron so now the iron we're
gonna heat the iron this is iron wool
which you might use for treating wood
and we're going to heat that till it's
warm and put it in the chlorine the
chlorine will oxidize it to iron
chloride chlorine will react with all
sorts of metals you can make salt by
burning the metal sodium in chlorine and
if you put in other metals like
aluminium or iron they will also react
aluminium reacts to form aluminium
trichloride which the salt of aluminium
and iron will similarly react to form
iron chloride and most metals but not
all of them will react with chlorine
lead will not for example but it is
really quite a reactive gas
so really Rapid Reaction there as the
hot iron starts to react with the
chlorine to form iron chloride very very
exothermic again and I think yes this is
very hot we might have to move it off
the paper so what happens in all of
these reactions is that the chlorine
removes an electron from the metal to
make the chloride an CL minus and the
chloride an is perfectly innocuous you
can drink you can eat chlorine fluoride
whereas chlorine itself is very
poisonous
what's warm it's not too hot to touch
it's like picking up a mug of warm tea
or a warm coffee but you can see again
the products of the chemical reaction
that precipitated out across the flask
and now if I remove the flower the wire
again I can see that all of the iron has
been consumed instantly the moment that
it got into that chlorine rich flask
very very rapid reaction very very
reactive with chlorine